against Ukraine and over the last weeks
and months we have seen Fierce fighting
in and around bakmud and what we see is
that Russia is throwing in more troops
more forces and what Russia lacks in the
quality they try to make up in quantity
they have suffered big losses but at the
same time we can not rule out that
um
may eventually fall in the coming days
and therefore it is also important to
highlight that this does
not necessarily
reflect any turning point of the war and
and
it just highlights that we should not
underestimate Russia we must continue to
provide support to Ukraine and NATO
allies have over the last year supported
Ukraine with military and financial and
economic support worth
around or close to
150 billion euros out of which 65
billion euros is military support this
is in particularly important to ramp up
production of ammunition this is an
issue that that NATO allies have
addressed for some time and we are now
going to agree
new guidelines new requirements for
stockpiles or ammunition ensuring that
we both can replenish our own stockpiles
but also to continue to provide support
to Ukraine
and
NATO allies have assigned contracts and
are welcome that I have signed contracts
with the defense industry to ramp or
production give them the long-term
demand signals and several NATO allies
are also
gone into joint projects or procurement
of different types of ammunition but
also
warehousing for ammunition
um
I look forward to meet the EU defense
ministers to discuss these issues and
and all the challenges we Face together
and what we have seen throughout the war
in Ukraine is how NATO and the European
Union Stand Together complement each
other and work together and to protect
our values it's a Secretary General
there have been reports that a
pro-ukrainian group attacked the north
stream pipelines last year can you
confirm this and what knowledge does
NATO have in this respect so what we do
know
is that there was an attack against the
north stream pipelines uh an act of
sabotage but we have not been able to
determine who was behind there are
ongoing National investigations and I
think it's a right to wait until those
are finalized before we send him more
about who was behind what we also know
is that
is that it demonstrates the importance
of protecting our critical undersea
infrastructure because we have thousands
of kilometers of gas pipelines of oil
pipelines of power grids and also of
course all the internet cables and all
of these uh infrastructure is critical
for our societies NATO has addressed
this for many years but after the
attacks against the north stream
pipelines we have stepped up we have
established a cell at the NATO
headquarters to coordinate efforts among
NATO allies to share more information to
work with the private sector that often
owns this infrastructure and to do more
to
minimize the risk and increase the
protection of critical undersea
infrastructure
you yourself have repeatedly warned that
Ukraine is running out of ammunition are
you satisfied with the pace of EU
countries and NATO countries in ramping
up production capacities
this is now a war of attrition which is
a battle of logistics this is about you
know getting the the supplies the
ammunition fuel to the front lines to
the soldiers and this was clearly all
the last fall and that's the reason why
NATO stepped up its efforts on working
with the industry and ramping up
production and also how we started the
work of uh uh developing new
requirements for stockpiles as part of
the NATO defense planning process our
capability targets and allies NATO
allies have all the design contracts
which have enabled increased production
this is good this is something I welcome
but it is an enormous demand out there
the the the current rate of consumption
compared to the current rate of
production of a nation of ammunition is
not sustainable and therefore we need to
ramp our production uh and a welcome
um that the European Union is stepping
up NATO allies are stepping up and we
already have joint projects among NATO
allies to provide both more ammunition
for artillery more ammunition for air
defense systems and also better
infrastructure warehousing for the
ammunition so this is something we have
we are working on we have seen important
steps already been taken but we need to
do more because we need to ensure that
Ukraine gets diminishing it needs to
defend itself against Russia's War
aggression and we need to replenish our
own stocks because so far
our support to Ukraine has mainly come
from depleting NATO stocks and of course
in the long run that's not sustainable
that's the reason why we have already
started the work on ramping or
production
will there be any breakthrough or will
nothing happen until the election in
Turkey thank you
first of all we have to remember that
all NATO allies also turkey made an
historic decision at the NATO Summit
last June in in June last year when they
all agreed to invite Finland and Sweden
to become a NATO allies since then we
have integrated Finland Sweden into NATO
civilian and Military structures and
Sweden and Finland has a totally
different status
being now more and more closely
integrated into NATO and several NATO
allies have also provided security
assurances to Finland and and Sweden
NATO has increased its presence in this
region and altogether this means that
it's inconceivable that there will be
any military threat against Finland and
Sweden without NATO reacting so Finland
and Sweden are in a much safer much
better position now than before they
applied that's good for Finland and
Sweden but it's also good for NATO
second I met with President adiron a
couple of weeks ago that was a good
meeting
uh I was there to express my condolences
after earthquake but also to discuss how
NATO could provide support to to Turkey
after the earthquake but we also
discussed the way forward on membership
and we are making progress uh uh
president adron agreed to restart the
talks
and to have a meeting Finland Sweden and
turkey
headquarters tomorrow and that in itself
is an important thing after a long
period out any talks this is a process
and I don't expect the process to be
concluded tomorrow but I'm confident
that Finance in will become NATO allies
this is a top priority and we are going
to continue to integrate financing into
our alliance
thank you thank you